murder mystery this was shot in Italy
yes beautiful part of Italy yes and this
has got to be like a dream place to
shoot a movie that was amazing yes we
shot a few different Portofino we shot
up in Milan was shot on Lake Como we did
it all and yeah yeah it was it was
unbelievable I have a story for when I
got home mm-hmm okay so Italy of course
is fun and good and you eat a lot
anyways I come home and I and I'm in bed
after that long summer I'm laying in bed
it's like and you just got back from it
just got back from Italy I'm laying in
bed I started to have a heart attack so
I'm I'm 52 so I say okay here comes my
heart attack and I'm laying there going
oh my god
my wife and kids I feel bad for them
they're gonna miss me so much then I'm
laying there going why should i call
9-1-1 something's going on just heart
attack hurts a lot and then i went wait
a minute I think I I have to take an
Italian dump Perino so what it was what
happened was I ate so many pizzas in
Italy it was stuck in my chest and I was
just laying it on I'm having a heart
attack
I realize after I went to the bathroom
and enjoyed maybe four or five minutes
of letting go I felt good again and then
it turned out it was just a case of the
old Italian shifts all right
okay that was a life-affirming outdoor
yeah I like it'd be a whole audience
just like yeah I let them in my life I'm
an open door show that you're a real
poison that's it